[Musique]
oui
on
c'est l'histoire d'une princesse
ensorcelé par une fée malveillantes
à l'aube de ses 16 ans aurore se pique
le doigt et s'endort jusqu'au baiser
d'un prince la belle au bois dormant 1da
les contes de fées revisité par le
chorégraphe français jean guillaume bart
pour mâles de cette princesse elle
symbole de de la lumière de la de la
jeunesse et de dunes c'est une promesse
de bonheur finalement et que par ce
sortilège cette promesse de bonheur
c'est un et elle se réveille grâce
effectivement à la fée lilas qui vient
qui va chercher le prince dans un pays
très reculé et tout finit bien le mal
est vraiment tuée par l'amour composé de
75 danseurs la troupe du jakobson ballet
de saint pétersbourg redonne vie aux
chefs-d'oeuvre musicale de tchaïkovski
un travail mené depuis février 2016
il s'inspire du ballet de marius petipa
2890 devenu l'un des plus célèbres de
l'histoire de la danse
[Musique]
il n'a pas été simple finalement de me
détacher de ce que je connaissais par
coeur pour essayer de revenir à des
choses peut-être plus plus traditionnels
notamment dans la tradition russe que
j'ai voulu respecter puisque c'est aussi
avec des danseurs russes que j'ai
travaillé l'école russe est très
expressive notamment dans les ports de
bras dans les dents les expressifs
l'expression des des épaulements ils ont
ils ont vraiment une qualité de peur de
braque nous n'avons pas dans l'école
française
je pense que c'est voilà c'est un
spectacle idéal pour les fêtes de fin
d'année considéré comme le ballet des
ballets par son caractère majestueux et
raffinée la belle au bois dormant sous
déguste comme une gourmandise un
savoureux mélange entre danse et fait
[Musique]